E aí
[Aplausos]
e a pandemia trouxe o efeito que atuou
de diferentes formas eu trago aqui uma
foto de antes da pandemia cês vão ver
que em mim o efeito foi que a minha
barba cresceu meu cabelo cresceu eu
aumentei um pouco peso pelo contexto do
sedentarismo e em casa os meus filhos e
minha esposa passaram a me dar o apelido
de Náufrago na prática a pandemia ela
acelerou também muita coisa a gente teve
uma aceleração bastante grande na
transformação digital nas organizações
bem como a gente viu a evolução dos
produtos digitais sejam aplicativos
sejam sites o próprio uso do WhatsApp é
as empresas passaram a usar essas
propriedades para se relacionar com os
seus clientes de uma maneira mais ativa
pelo fato da gente não tem mais as
pessoas no presencial e quando a gente
fala há conexões a gente está falando de
conexões entre pessoas e na visão das
conexões das pessoas quais empresas a
gente também tem que entender que é as
empresas são feitas de gente então as
conexões continuam sendo feitas entre
pessoas e a tecnologia ela veio para
servir de e-mail de canal e facilitar
esse processo
quando a gente fala de conexões a gente
fala de conexões entre pessoas a gente
está falando de conexões fortes conexões
verdadeiras e a gente está
experimentando a oportunidade de criar
essas conexões fortes essas conexões
verdadeiras com os clientes e usuários
dos nossos produtos digitais a
necessidade de evoluir e acelerar as
conexões fortes com as pessoas através
de propriedade digitais fez com que a
gente incentivasse cada vez mais esse
meio o e nisso a gente tem dois grandes
componentes que a gente pode trazer como
viabilizadores dessa aceleração o
primeiro componente é um componente
emocional e o segundo componente é um
componente de engajamento
falando sobre o componente emocional a
gente tem empatia ética EA colaboração
como três principais atributos nesse
momento né de pandemia uma campanha que
me chamou muita atenção a campanha da
Havaianas onde ele colocam ali um teaser
uma chamada para você se colocar no
calçado do outro tem tudo a ver com o
momento e com a necessidade de a gente
trazer o contexto da empatia para dentro
das nossas organizações com uma força
maior quando a gente fala do componente
engajamento os três atributos que me vem
à mente primeiros são a personalização
a comunicação EA valorização há um tempo
atrás O Google ele teve a ideia de levar
para as populações ribeirinhas na
Amazônia a oportunidade de usar pesquisa
do Google como a gente sabe a
infraestrutura nessas regiões é uma é
uma infraestrutura que não dispõe de
internet de alta velocidade através de
uma rede 2G ou seja suportada
principalmente por voz ele
disponibilizar um serviço de pesquisa
deles por um número uma espécie de 0800
onde é a população poderia ligar e por
exemplo também fazer um pedido uma
pesquisa de uma receita de bolo de
macaxeira por exemplo no que diz
respeito à comunicação eu acho que a
gente aprendeu muito que a comunicação é
ativa ela é uma prerrogativa assim para
o engajamento mas mais do que e
comunicarmos E falarmos para o cliente
aquilo que tem de novo ou aquilo que a
gente está disponibilizando para ele a
gente passou a ouvir esse cliente e a
ouvir esse cliente a gente trouxe ele
para próximo da nossa estratégia para
que ele se apropriasse da oportunidade
de ser um dos pilares da nossa
estratégia a visão de câncer mês entre
que de trazer o cliente para o centro
das suas decisões Passa muito pelo
feedback desses clientes e pela escuta
ativa nesse momento também a gente é
experimentou Uma nova oportunidade No
que diz respeito à valorização
desses nossos clientes e usuários esses
usuários esses clientes das propriedades
digitais eles passaram a ser essenciais
para a continuidade do negócio e por
conta disso foram criados ainda o
spandidos programas de fidelidade
benefícios exclusivos em um contexto
muito grande de
valorização para que esse cliente ele
passasse além de ser fiel ser leal um
exemplo pessoal e que mostra um pouco da
Visão contrária a essa evolução essa
aceleração desses dois componentes
aconteceu comigo há mais ou menos cinco
anos atrás eu participei de um Reality
Show O bbq Brasil do SBT e na época a
gente uma comunicação muito ativa porque
o programa é transmitido em broadcast
então haviam engajamento grande tanto
por pessoas que torciam por mim no
programa como propor aquelas que torciam
por outras pessoas e então estavam
contra mim e uma das coisas que é
interessante desse desse exemplo é que
da mesma forma com os produtos digitais
das organizações a gente tem que tentar
transformar os detratores em promotores
e foi o que eu tentei fazer ao longo O
que é do programa no resumo o que a
gente entende que faz sentido dentro da
visão de colocar o cliente no centro de
ter mais empatia de melhor a comunicação
de valorizar E todos os outros atributos
que a gente conversou tenho uma questão
central que é os nossos produtos
digitais eles têm que ser adaptáveis aos
nossos clientes então não são os nossos
clientes que têm que se adaptar aos
nossos produtos digitais e sim o
contrário e para falar um pouco ou para
pelo menos deixar um teaser uma
provocação sobre o que de fato seriam
conexões do próximo futuro tanto o ser
Richard branson como o Mister Jeff bezos
disputando agora essa corrida pelo
turismo espacial E se a gente foi
imaginar aqui o turismo espacial ele
está sendo feito no outro ambiente com
uma alimentação de eu tenho e outras
questões como será que a gente vai se
conectar daqui para frente né o a partir
desse momento em que estiver possível
para todo mundo é será que a gente vai
se comunicar através de máquinas Como No
Filme o substituto em que o Bruce Willis
ali tem um Android e consegue fazer todo
o controle de sensibilidade e de
comunicação desse Android sem precisar
estar presencialmente em algum lugar
será que a gente vai realmente se
substituído entre aspas por máquinas e
virar algo que faz parte de um contexto
de conexão muito mais futurista Isso é
uma provocação que eu deixo aqui queria
agradecer muito obrigado e até a próxima
E aí